tendo a tutti ragazzi minuti questo
video sono fa vj perché sto facendo così
non ne ho la piu pallida cazzo di idea
ed agisce 1 sul video un po particolare
molti di voi ragazzi sanno e lo so che
lo sapete tutti che youtube ha la
funzione i sottotitoli nel senso che c'è
un tastino che se cliccate youtube mette
i sottotitoli la maggior parte delle
volte questi sottotitoli sono generati
automaticamente da quello che youtube
capisce del video quindi youtube a un
sistema che riconosce la voce e mette i
sottotitoli secondo voi questo sistema
funziona bene
marco per il cazzo ovviamente sì come
youtube quando dici telefono capisce
preservativo escono fuori delle frasi
che veramente non stanno né in cielo né
in terra ho deciso di fare un video sui
sottotitoli di youtube farai una
reactions i sottotitoli che youtube
mette partiamo dal trailer di titanic
siccome ho fatto la reaction già del
blog per vedere come sarebbe stato coi
sottotitoli buona visione
ma sono i sottotitoli [ __ ] e non anche
attivati e poi la traduzione in italiano
larry hagman pedro che grazie al gol di
rai
grazie grazie ai gol di razza ciriani
adesso si è capito che cazzo ha fatto
naufragare i titani sono stati gol di
razza giliani se non fosse stato per lui
parlando dell'eliminazione delle
conseguenze ora secondo il capo del
nuovo giornale rappresentati detto di
diverso scopi ragazzi mi fate vedere il
trailer di ge intera fi con i
sottotitoli vi prego voglio capire che
ai preparati inizia l'agghia inter p
miti e leggende ho detto ho detto
proprio miti e leggende io voi non avete
capito ho detto proprio questo il
fotovoltaico ci ricordiamo tutti una
delle scene più celebri o quella quella
della cucina si è perché c'è scritto ci
vogliamo tutti una delle scene che
celebrino quella [ __ ] della cucina
secondo ragazzi allora io io ho un
ipotesi puccio questa idea secondo me è
dietro il sottotitolo di youtube ci sono
delle scimmie le scimmie che ascoltano è
è traducono il live però sono scimmie
perché non posso capire che cazzo di
problemi abbia arrivano ad un passo dai
bambini che si sono nascosti per cercare
posso dei bambini che si sono sposati
verrà a cercare di girerà loro furia
nostre alla loro mourinho beh ragazzi
sono fa vi sono un sono francesca 6
francesca porca vecchie c'hai dei
capelli che manco mortisia della
famiglia addams però zio però dovrei
essere fa vj pino torinese faringei
diciamo facendo capelli a display
un certo stella che cosa con le tre
stelle con un supereroe un super eroe
invincibile che non si fanno mai male
questa era una una quasi giu brava
scimmia dalla madonna otto sono le
bestemmie non ho mai detto una roba del
cio si tiene tutto il cazzo col cazzo si
è messa perché sennò nola mettevi senza
il cazzo quando sparì quando squali
certamente pari del trittico di cesarò
bravo l'odio per tutto verdure che
questa roba ragazzi si scopre in realtà
che è uno strumento fatto col cazzo è
uno strumento da cucina per vegani per
installare pane di segale perché quello
è esattamente del pane di segale favara
come esplode il pane di segala facebook
a nessuno ha detto un cazzo però è
uscita la scritta facebook
io ho appena notato una cosa che mi ha
fatto uscire la light bar che c'è in me
una giornata confavi cazzo livido chi ha
riso libero
nessuno sta dicendo in piazza cosa
scrivo mai facebook anzi sono corretti
adesso perché prima avranno sbagliato il
macello
[Musica]
odano paolo gol un po di senso graziano
e ci vediamo cina ci vediamo al cinema
però cinema città brescia quindi solo a
brescia non esistono cinema se non a
brescia complimenti per il finale molto
sexy
voglio un altra roba così c'è una
intervista aveva fatto qualsiasi tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
son of a voi pensate che io abbia sempre
detto bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
a questo video sono fuori j
in realtà io ho sempre detto non te la
prendere a separare dalla storia sono si
chiama slide è conosciutissimo si chiama
salento polonia possiamo notare un
gradissimo esemplare di slang un
gravissimo e gravi oso sono le
intenzioni di lorenzo ostuni in arte
lorenzo tunisina che io volevo se ho
sempre voluto chiamarmi lorenzo tunisina
c'è perché carasso vuoi metterti in arte
dj sono virtual dj macaco tre video osè
ragazzi grazie che capire che pensate
queste cose di meglio quando vi chiedo
il parere vostro poi mi rispondete
sempre macaco tre video ci mancherebbe
altro
con tale nostre telecamere lorenzo
alcuni è un team lorenzo sculli ma
cristo santo ma ce l'ha fatta a mettere
il mio cognome scimmia cosa ti stai
bevand come siamo passati da lorenzo
tunisina lorenzo scullino ragazzo come
tanti altri
il mio ragazzo come tanti altri chi sta
a fare come corno ci siano ragazzi prima
vedere quello su ogni gol che quanto
cosa esce fuori
susan tosto porno non sto dicendo niente
in italiano ok dune un commento ma ve
devo dire che non me lo ricordo questo
video ricordo con il solito scaltro
grande uomo
cazzo se la quarta una frase ce la può
fare a farla bene una ha una palla che
un favi dei come si legge sta roba para
parlando caribe dei anche con me anche
come dove sei stata 123 gomme anche no
però vabbè sei stata karaoke varese è
stata cara base
ciao carissimi non so dove la legge ora
sentito taranto 6 mag versione donna 6
me versione don matteo
[Musica]
sono giapponese in realtà non ne non
vuol dire ne sono giapponese ne assumi
giapponese ma vuol dire sono giapponese
assoluto punto il momento di pausa prima
porto pescara cosa sei click cosa
antonio acciaio sono lì sotto [ __ ]
[ __ ] non l'hanno visto 8 ma cosenza c'è
un umano lì sotto ma non è capito [ __ ]
ragazzi concludo che l'episodio e adesso
voglio che voi voi date una spiegazione
a questo ho bisogno di sapere che cosa
cazzo ne pensate perché non è possibile
strada per ragazze con culo
dell'episodio è stata io potrei ragazze
con cu lo finisco di treviso trattamenti
piante dei piedi
se ci vediamo subito bellaria bellaria
quindi io quando chiudo il video in
realtà di bellaria bella a tutti i
ragazzi bella tutti i ragazzi l'ha preso
poi ha detto belen ma non c'entra un
cazzo
l'importante è che l'abbia preso dai gay
casa che fa la ragazza di gay comfort
c'aveva ragione i bambini di 7 anni a
scriverlo sciascia ragazzi è stato un
video a caso proprio perché santo iddio
mirate io i sottotitoli di youtube li ho
sempre tolti dalla vita perché mi
distraggo non hanno senso perché non mi
fa capire un cazzo del video se fanno
così kakanj sottotipi ma non li mette
fari domanda favi cazzo domanda chi
scrive queste cose chi chiede fatemelo
sapere grazie perché è uno è un quesito
che non riescono non ha risposto starò
lasciate un mi piace per tutto non c'è
niente che che meriti di per tutto il
video è una roba senza senso spero che
mi serve 100 ragazzi senza vita è
piaciuto come non mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e con il video
trascrizione salvi di scriverci vi diamo
seguito bello ragazzi cliccate sui
sottotitoli eri guardatevi questo video
coi sottotitoli perché voglio vedere che
cazzo ragazzi